eq les risques d'inondation continue
d'inquiéter les riverains je joins
claudine richard à sherbrooke mais tout
d'abord pascal le point là à boischatel
et un embâcle de glace qui risquent de
céder sous peu sur la rivière
montmorency michel en fait on est à la
limite de beauport et à la limite de
boischatel implanter deux mois et
toujours à la ville de québec on va vous
montrer cet embâcle en question michel
alors effectivement si la rivière
montmorency les glaces que vous voyez
donc au loin un peu de vendre les
chalets qui sont derrière c'est un
embâcle qui risquent de céder cet
embâcle s'étend sur 1 à 2 kilomètres de
long en amont de la rivière montmorency
on nous dit que ça commence à être
problématique à partir du moment où les
débits sont à plus de 30 mètres par
seconde lorsque ça dépasse 100 mètres
par seconde
l'embâcle risque de céder et là on est à
160 mètres par seconde de débit de la
rivière montmorency
donc c'est pas sûr que l'embâcle va
céder mais il pourrait céder vous dans
les prochaines heures donc effectivement
ce sera déterminant la ce qui va se
passer dans les prochaines heures
évidemment avec la pluie
l'on comprend que le cours d'eau est en
train de se gonfler ce qui fait en sorte
qu'il ya des risques mais pour l'instant
personne n'a été évacuée dans le secteur
même si tout le monde est sur le qui
vive
pascal il faut parler de cet homme qui a
été secouru par hélicoptère à stoneham
ils étaient coincés sur la rivière
cachée et lui oui michel parce qu'il
était parti allait voir ce qui se
passait pour ses chiens de traîneaux il
en entreprise de chiens de traîneaux cet
homme mais il devait se rendre à son
chenil en nageant en passant un par un
pont suspendu est arrivé au milieu du
pont l'embâcle a cédé il était pris il
avait de la glace jusqu'aux cuisses
il a appelé sa femme qui a appelé les
secours que finalement ils réussissent à
venir la secourir par hélicoptère comme
vous le voyez sur les images on va
entendre justement le des responsables
de ce sauvetage qui parlait au téléphone
avec l'homme pour le rassurer
alors je pense qu'on me dit qu'on n'a
pas on ne peut pas entendre cet extrait
me bref c'est quand même une histoire
michel qui se termine bien parce que
l'homme en question a été transporté à
l'hôpital et
évidemment on soigne ses blessures un
peu d'hypothermie mais ça va bien tant
mieux
merci pascal au revoir au revoir michel